happy to welcome on to the program now
marcia santini the nurse
from the appeal video who works at the
medical center of the university of
california
in los angeles marcia welcome how are
you
firstly how long did it take for you to
recover from covatellus
i'm on my um 20th day
i'm probably 95 better but i still have
residual shortness of breath and
some weird neurological um sensations
that i get
yeah we can only wish you the best with
that marcia in terms of the overall
picture
how stretched are hospitals in l.a right
now what what are you expecting as we
enter into the
the new year oh
gosh we are um beyond stretched
we have patients in overflow overflow
overflow areas that
were never intended to have coveted
patients
other hospitals are setting up makeshift
units outside of the hospital we are
just in the last we're dealing with the
last search from thanksgiving now we're
going to have to deal with the search
from
christmas and then we have new year's
coming so we're going to be dealing with
this for
quite some time now what can be done
then to to give the health system enough
of a boost to cope as you say with
what's looking
to be a third wave here
i i'm afraid that we've already passed
that people didn't listen and
we um we're stuck now we
we were running low on oxygen on
supplies
on you know all the respiratory drugs
definitely beds
um definitely staff we don't have enough
staff
so we've already but we blew it the
the public didn't listen we continued to
um defy the recommendations of the cdc
and we continued to gather
and um i understand how important
holidays are they're just as important
for me i haven't
seen my family in months um
so we need it's too late
we we blew it are authorities giving
enough help marcia to you as you talk
about that
having enough beds having enough
personal protective equipment
has that been supplied
authorities in what way like trying to
enforce stay-at-home measures
well even to bulk up what you have we
know that you have to buy it of course
but
in terms of just the helping hand you
mean like like government supplies
absolutely yeah yeah i
you know our government again they blew
it all so they could have um released
the
defense production act and ramped up the
production of ppe
and and all the other supplies that we
need and they didn't do that
so the whole the whole nation's in a big
big
predicament of how we're going to be
able to treat patients safely
and give them the care that they need
you're one of those people battling it
at the coal face right on the on the
front line
can you give us a sense really marcia of
your of the timeline perhaps
some of your experiences about working
since the start of the pandemic
well you know at the very beginning of
the pandemic um
we were quite fortunate where i work at
ucla we didn't see the numbers that
the you know some of the nation was
seeing and even some of our state in
northern california and southern
california
san diego were getting hit much harder
um so we were lucky we had time to
prepare and get ready
um and then we kind of got relaxed
thinking
that the we're never going to see the
numbers
um until halloween and thanksgiving came
and now we're getting
um slammed but um
it's been a an interesting roller
coaster
ride um seeing how this has all been
playing out
but we're we we hit the perfect storm
right now because
a very dangerous storm because we're not
only
seeing other sick patients you know our
strokes our heart attacks our cancer
patients
but we're short staffed and we're short
on real estate
and supplies so it's a very dangerous
time right now
and the public needs to know that i was
going to say
i don't think it's overstating it to say
that there's anguish in your voice from
from what you've been through from what
you've seen from
the colleagues you've been working with
if you had a message
marcia for people just listening in what
would it be right now for those thinking
well you know it's not that serious well
there's two things one it's terribly
serious and people need to understand
that
i i had the best protection that i
possibly could have
every single day i wore it i practiced
it and i still got it
secondly this is not over this isn't far
from over
the vaccines are not going to
i mean yes they're going to help but
it's going to take a lot of time before
we can vaccinate
everyone and we don't necessarily just
get vaccinated and it goes away we have
to continue to wear the protective
equipment social distance
and and practice everything that the cdc
is recommending
um until we get a good
grip on this virus and that's going to
take months it's not over
and we can't get relaxed we can't get
lazy we can't get
fatigued about it we must continue or
else
we're going to be dealing with this over
and over and over again
well we've been speaking to somebody
with a direct
experience of working on those front
lines marcy thank you very much for
coming on the program
marcia santini a nurse at the medical
center of the university of california
in los angeles